elle était la favorite de ce second tour
marie louise fort repart pour six ans à
la tête de sens
malgré sa réélection avec plus de 50%
des suffrages
la maire sortante a du mal à ses
origines rire l'abstention gâche un peu
la fête
j'ai des grands parents qui m'ont
toujours dit quand on a le droit de vote
pour l'exercer quoi qu'il arrive je
voudrais dire ça à tous ceux qui ne sont
pas venus voter non pas pour leur dire
que c'est pas bien mais pour leur dire
que les politiques jusqu'à je suis pas
la seule les ont entendus et vont faire
en sorte qu'on redonne envie de voter ce
dimanche à peine un tiers des électeurs
sénonais sont allés voter une faible
mobilisation qui n'a pas profité à
julian odoul et au rassemblement
national 14 % et seulement deux sièges
au conseil municipal
c'était un non sens pour le premier tour
c'est un non sens pour ce second tour
on le voit partout en france on le voit
peut-être encore plus à sens donc c'est
malheureux d'en arriver là parce que ces
six années importantes six années de
gestion municipale six années de projets
cette année de vie quotidienne qui vont
manquer légitimité tout simplement une
élection qui n'aura pas non plus sourit
à la gauche laurent moinet ne récolte
que 23% des suffrages
quant à l'écologiste matthew bitoun il
termine quatrième après avoir convaincu
moins de 13 % des électeurs
si vous voulez vous êtes sur une
quadrangulaire donc avec une division
mathématiques j'allais dire des des
listes et des chiffres et puis et puis
peut-être aussi une division dé gauche
et une responsabilité à faire porter
celui qui aujourd'hui termine 4e nous on
est très heureux de faire rentrer deux
conseillers au conseil municipal de sens
qui seront des vrais écologistes ont qui
porteront nos propositions à la fois
pour l'environnement et pour la justice
sociale
qu'on arrête d'accumuler du retard à
sens et on donnera toute notre énergie
pour ça à 69 ans marie louise fort
s'apprête à débuter son troisième mandat
à sens
le nouveau conseil municipal sera
installé le 3 juillet